à genoux
qu'est-ce que tu es sorti
tu m'as manqué c'est bon de te
revoir rouler et je suis passé chez Alice qu'est-ce que
tu vois à 14 ans tu ressembles à ta
mère ben bonjour Vincent je veux ma part
des 10 millions de dollars que j'allais  pour
changer nos vies
tes nouvelles nouveau cash et fille il y a du
sucre vraiment sympa
où est-elle
ton ancien partenaire a kidnappé une
bouteille dans sa tenue du taxi je ne suis
pas joué par tu veux lui parler
maintenant tout dépend de lui pour sauver  sa
fille ce n'est plus une femme
je manque de temps il n'a que 12
heures tu ne penses pas qu'il est sur la vérité
non je ne vole pas dix milliards de dollars
feu le plus gros de la Paris Community
Bank
je veux ça  mec cloue ton père
me debout et je vais lui faire payer
pour nous deux
je vais te sortir de là